Thank you.
But then someone came by and it actually ended up being like an ordeal.
But hello, I hope you're doing well.
I hope it's nice out there.
It is not, well, I mean, you're out in the desert, right?
So, I don't know, the desert's a pretty broad thing.
I don't think that's really talking to someone, but I apologize if it sounds like it.
But where you are, it's normal, but I don't know, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know if it's, I used to live in the avenues in my SLC, out in the west of the United States.
And when I was out there in the West of the United States, I don't really remember when
it was never really cold to me because it was always very dry when it was cold.
It wasn't that hot either.
But it is, we were supposed to have a, like, warmer than normal month.
And they had predicted that the days were all going to be 60s and 70s now.
And we're, like, struggling between the 40s and the 50s.
And it is incredibly depressing.
I'm not a person who's prone to depression.
I just have tremendous low energy from all kinds of physical problems.
But I got to say that when they say it's going to be warm and then it isn't warm, it's not too good.
Hey, Bark Like a Duck, how you doing?
I was just saying, I was just, well, talking to Melissa, but, you know, she's a listener, not a speaker.
I was just saying that I originally thought this was going to be my first zero listener space.
But you guys are, I always show up, it's great.
Thank you.
And then I started complaining about the weather in Massachusetts, which I guess no one wants to hear about.
I mean, I would hope no one would want to hear about it.
Everyone would have more going on in their life.
I'm exhausted and I'm a little bit, I don't know if depressed is the word from the weather.
But also, I don't know, I think you both, I don't know, maybe Melissa, I don't think follows the UFO X.
Bark Like a Duck, I think you follow UFO X stuff.
I think that's, but I'm not positive about that.
I get confused easily, so don't hold it against me.
There's a new drama.
And the new drama is the cancellation of a host of a podcast.
I don't listen to these podcasts.
I've never heard anyone, I've never seen or heard anyone in a space or in a podcast say anything new of any importance since I started listening to stuff on X like the last few years.
In the 90s, it seemed like, you know, at least the information was new to me.
Just all old rehashed shit.
And now everyone has video on their cell phones, so now people don't see the UFOs anymore, right?
They see orbs.
I'm not going to say orbs are an artifact of phones.
They used to say that with, like, cameras, that orbs were an artifact of the process of developing the photos.
At that time, we generally didn't see the orbs, right?
So originally what orbs were, were, I mean, I'm sure, I don't know how old you guys are, but, you know, orbs originally were colored orbs in photos, particularly Polaroid photos.
But you'd also develop them in, you take photos of yourself at a barbecue and you develop and there'd be like a green orb flying through or blue orb flying through, usually green or red, I think, green, I think, for some reason.
And it was just considered to be an artifact of the development process, but people would say that, no, it's some sort of paranormal thing that you can only see in the film.
You don't see it, generally speaking, in day-to-day life.
Sometimes people would see them at night in the woods, right?
Will-o'-the-wisps, as we know from European folklore.
But the orbs themselves didn't become a real big thing until, they didn't become a real big thing until people were no longer able to claim that they were taking or experiencing having UFOs hover over their house because they weren't able to take,
you know, they didn't have video of them and they should have the video of them.
So, um, then all of a sudden everyone started seeing warps, but I have seen the photos and I don't know if it's created by like, uh, Photoshop or AI or whatever of the little metal balls.
Those are interesting.
Um, those, I don't remember if those were ever a thing.
They might've been, uh, they're definitely a thing now and people have pictures of them up all over the place.
I don't know if I remember hearing about them historically.
And if the idea is that, uh, that there is, uh, an elusive companion civilization, um, another species living here that we, or another branch of humanity living here that we can't perceive who are using these orbs as like a planetary defense or a form of surveillance.
Um, I think we would have heard about them a lot more in the past and we definitely see them in like paintings, right?
Cause we see UFOs and paintings.
So we know that people, you know, going all the way back, UFOs and paintings and frescoes going back hundreds, if not thousands of years.
So, um, we know that people saw them or saw something at that time.
Uh, and there's even like a famous, there are some famous historical events, uh, in the 15 or 1600s, there was a, a war over Nuremberg, Germany, where they had, uh, UFOs fighting it out in the sky.
At least that's what it's, you know, it's recorded historically, um, that these flying objects were fighting it out with each other in the sky.
Um, yeah.
Um, but I don't remember anyone talking about metal orbs.
So I'll have to look into that.
You know, one of the problems, um, that's apropos to the subject today is in the, a lot of the books put out in the eighties and nineties were put out through independent booksellers.
They had limited printings and they used to be sold.
I don't know if you guys remember, there used to be a section.
I think there probably still is.
I think they call it a cult now, maybe in some places or new age and others.
But there used to be a large section in bookstores where they would have, um, magic books, UFO books.
Uh, hey Sally.
They'd have, uh, you know, magic books, UFO books, things on the pyramid.
They would also have alternative history.
They would lump all, quote, alternative thoughts together and put it in one section in the bookstore.
Uh, loom panics was one of the companies.
Um, uh, David Hatcher Childress in Indiana.
He had a press, but I forget adventures unlimited press was another one for like four or five, um, independent, um, uh, presses booksellers and, and, um, printing presses that would print these alternative books on these different subjects.
Uh, a lot of those books never made it to the internet and they may be mentioned somewhere on the internet.
Some of them I've never been able to find on the internet.
Some of them might be mentioned somewhere, but there are no physical copies and no commentaries on them.
Uh, made it into the modern age, unless they're in someone's collection someplace that, you know, we're not going to see.
I think I have some in the basement, I don't know, uh, in boxes.
God knows what condition they're in after all this time, but it's, it's apropos because it's, we're almost blind.
Like the whole digital dark age thing, it hit, uh, alternative to, Hey Morgan, it hit the alternative community, like really hard.
And that's one of the reasons that we have this, this issue with these influencers now, uh, Ben, for instance, the guy who does the sun weather man.
He, he's, I don't want to make an allegation that I have to refute, but some people would say, and in my opinion, uh, he's drawn, uh, a lot, if not most everything, um, that he talks about.
He's, he's drawn it from old sources, old coast to coast AM guests in the nineties.
We were all around at that time.
And because the books really, they didn't make it onto the internet.
Um, and no one remembers those authors, no one really cites those sources anymore.
And I think in some cases it's impossible to do so, but I think you could say like, Hey, I learned this from other people.
As opposed to representing it as your own, um, innovations and discoveries.
I, I certainly know that I haven't heard him say anything that I found surprising or unusual based on my experience.
So there was nothing that I was like, Oh wow.
He came up with that.
That's a great idea.
No, it's, it's all stuff in my opinion, I've heard before in the past.
Um, and, and you, you find this a lot in the alternative influencer community right now.
Um, it just recombinations of the nineties.
The reason that I was thinking about this, um, there's a, there used to be in a number of these books, there was a picture of a temple in Tibet that had a rock in front of it, big old rock in the picture.
But how big it really was, I don't know.
Um, and as a matter of fact, it may have not even been that big, right?
Because I'm remembering something from 30 years ago.
Uh, I have looked far and wide on the internet on a number of occasions in the last 10 or 15 years for, um, information about that picture information about that temple.
So a couple of things have happened, um, one, you know, without getting into a political thing, um, you know, Tibet was invaded, uh, and the Chinese have destroyed all but 70.
I think several thousands temples have been torn down.
And what happens is they go in and they tear them down at night or when, when people aren't really around and they actually tear them down and they send people in to drag out the foundation.
So there's not a speck, not even the foundation is left from the temple and they claim it wasn't there.
Um, so, you know, the Tibetan community in exile will tell you that we're there and there are some pictures, but largely a lot of these temples and a lot of the information they contain, the documents they contained.
And, et cetera, have been wiped off the face of the earth intentionally.
Um, there's a tremendous influence, um, from the CCP, right?
Online.
And I'm not saying, I'm not going to confabulate and say, well, they're out there, you know, stopping esoteric Tibetan Buddhist information from getting out.
I don't know.
I'm just saying, I don't know, but I wouldn't be surprised because that's the type of thing that people do.
People often allege that they might do.
I do know, I can't find any information about this temple online.
Maybe someone else could.
Uh, but it, it's, you know, I clearly remember it and I have since the beginning of the internet.
So, um, the question is when the rock was placed there, there was, um, an inscription.
There was, um, the hell they call them, uh, plaque.
And the plaque had a date on it.
And the rock was there supposedly because it had been brought back from the moon.
And the date, that's where I'm a little iffy.
I believe it was around 4,000 BC.
But this is just my recollection 30 years later.
It could have been 1,400 BC.
When we talk about like a lot of the stuff that kind of happened, it's, it's all dated between like 1,000 and 3,000 BC.
And I think a lot of it really occurred around 2,000 BC.
But I can't be sure about that.
On the other hand, people who say that we're certain about the dates that things happened 4,000 years ago, they're lying.
They might be lying to themselves.
They might believe a lie that somebody else told them.
Um, but it's, it's not a true statement.
Like, we're not.
Um, you know, especially when you get into other cultures.
Because the calendars don't match exactly.
Like, someone went back and looked at the Chinese calendar and pieced it together.
Uh, with the Western calendar.
Using events, uh, eclipses.
And, uh, mostly eclipses.
But, but other events as well.
Like, historical events.
To try to reconcile the calendars.
Because this isn't a popular thing to say in the West.
But, uh, calendars have always been manipulated.
Historically, for political purposes.
There are people who will tell you that our chronology has not been manipulated.
But what most people don't realize is,
our chronology was pieced together in the 16th and 17th centuries.
Now, I'm not saying it's wrong.
Because, you know, I wasn't there.
But I am saying that, uh, as a coherent whole,
our, um, historical record did not exist prior to the 16th and 17th century.
It was in bits and pieces scattered around.
And somebody or a group of people got together and worked it out.
So, when you go down to, like, say, Mesoamerica, there's another calendar.
We still don't know, um,
exactly how our calendar syncs with their calendar.
There are some eclipses.
We think, uh, those eclipses,
you know, prove that certain dates are consistent.
But no one can say for sure, like, what date it is right now in the Aztec or Mayan calendars.
Because this is also an Aztec calendar.
Just like when we're talking about the Chinese calendar, we're talking about best guess, right?
And we talk about, like, things that happened in antiquity.
We're talking about, like, oh, hold on.
Now my screen is gone.
Okay.
So, when we talk about things that happened in antiquity, we're talking about things like,
we believe it happened then.
But people don't say that.
They'll be like, this happened in this year.
You know.
I mean, the Romans were pretty good.
There was probably some, still some political stuff going on with their calendar.
There's some big questions about the Middle Ages.
People might have heard this.
There were some people who alleged that 180 years was added.
There were some people alleged 700 years was added.
And I think it's gone up to the point where, like, saying 1,200 years were added.
I don't necessarily believe that.
But I do know that you can't rely on the dating, historically.
You have to just kind of go with it sometimes and use reason sometimes.
So, I don't know when the rock was left there.
But I do know that there are, and I think I was having a talk with Morgan about this, right?
Oh, someone dropped off.
Okay.
Oh, bye, Melissa.
Oh, she'll be back, I think.
Oh, no.
Melissa, you're there.
Oh, it's parked like a duck.
There are, it's not a myth, right?
Like, so, Zeus is a myth.
You could call them folktales.
You could call them legends.
It's not really mythological.
There are extensive cultural records in Asia or the Orient, right?
I use the term oriental because it means of the east.
And to be completely honest, we don't know if these events were localized in Asia or not.
There are speculations that may have been a continent off the coast of Asia, Colombia.
Hey, Senan.
Hey, Barb.
We definitely know there was a continent around Indonesia, connecting Indonesia and New Guinea and Australia.
So, we know that these events are localized in the area to the east of us, or of the east, right?
The Orient.
That word has fallen out of favor, and I specifically chose it because I have this horrible, like, soap opera thing where I pay attention to this UFOX stuff, and they're so politically correct.
Oh, it's brutal.
Even the people who represent themselves as being, you know, alternative right or alt-right, they're not.
They're woke, taking a contentious stand, which is fine.
People have a right to be whatever they want, but I'm just so tired of the Puritanism.
And part of that Puritanism is the embrace of Marxist language.
I'm not going to get into a huge, like, rant about it.
I'm just going to say, like, the reason we have an extreme political, I'm not political, but we have an extreme political government right now, right?
Whether you agree with it or not, is because we had an extreme political government four years ago.
And things have gotten more extreme because of things like, or the adoption of Marxist language stuff, like redefining words and phrases for political purposes every few years.
And there are people, there are people who will, particularly there are millennials who were raised this way, right?
Indoctrinated into this ideology, who if you say a word like oriental in front of them, oriental is from the Latin word orientalists, right?
That's not a slur.
It means of the East.
But when they were working out this language stuff, they came up with the idea that, you know, referring to something as being of the East means that you're setting the default position for humanity is the West, right?
Like, if you're defining everything as East of Europe, then you're inherently saying, like, Europe is the most important place.
It's colonialism.
And so in order to be anti-colonialist, you had to redefine the phrase oriental.
And in order to get people emotionally invested, you had to get everyone worked up.
And now everyone's running around like it's some kind of crazy slur when it means of the East.
It was never a slur at all.
And it's a word that is actually used when we got the, what makes me think about it is we got all the Japanese posters because of the new translation thing, which is obviously some sort of social engineering.
And I think we're going to be fighting a war, not against them, with them, against somebody else in the future.
And so this is probably an attempt to integrate us a little bit.
At the same time, like, we heard less, like, less people were posting from Russia and China at the same time.
They use the term oriental all the time.
I mean, it's a translation, right?
But it translates into oriental, right?
It doesn't translate into Asia because Asia doesn't mean of the East or of the West, right?
And I was just pissed off.
Because I was tired of the woke bullshit.
So I said, you know what?
We need to just put a stop.
Of course, my taking a small stand on the X basis doesn't make any difference.
But I think it's indicative because if somebody is going to see a word like oriental and make a judgment based on it, they have been so highly saturated by what, you know, extreme left politics, which is fine for extreme leftists.
I'm not saying they don't have the right to be, to have their politics.
But they've been so saturated by it that it's altered their worldview forever.
And I don't know if somebody who has that type of extreme worldview on either side politically is really interested in truth and facts.
Like, I don't think they're into UFOs for UFOs, right?
Like, you could say, okay, Bob is a white supremacist.
Now, I don't know what white supremacists mean, Bob, but let's just say, Bob is a white supremacist.
Bob is into UFOs.
Are UFOs his genuine passion?
Or is there a connection?
And often when you look into it, right?
In that case, you'll find some sort of ideological connection to some sort of revisionist history, pseudo-intellectual stuff equating UFOs with white supremacy, right?
And in the same way, if somebody is an extreme leftist Marxist, you know, and that's the right, you know, are they really looking at this information to discover the truth?
I know last year, I ran a space about the Hopi Red Kachina prophecy.
Now, I can't think of a non-biblical prophecy more apropos to our time.
And, you know, I was talking about how in the prophecy, when I first read it in the 90s, the prophecy talks about in the heart of all the cities, towards the end of the age, in the heart of all the cities, there will be these people who no longer have souls.
Now, that's a judgment.
It's not my judgment.
It's a judgment in the text.
Who no longer have souls.
And the weight of life will weigh so heavily down on them that they'll be bent over, and it will affect the way they walk, right?
They'll be like, and it's called the heroin knot, right?
And it's the fentanyl crisis.
Now, in the 1990s, it didn't make any sense.
It sounded kind of crazy.
In the 1990s, you did not see that.
But now, if you go to the heart of any major American city, you're going to find, like,
we have it in Boston called the methadone mile, and that's what people refer to it as.
You go down there, you're going to find 1,000 or 1,200 people staggering along.
And it looked like somebody put, I'm sure you've all seen it, but in case one of you hasn't, it looks like somebody put a 200-pound backpack on them.
And they're struggling, step by step.
So, you know, I bust that out because it's incredibly apropos.
And it also includes, right, so there's the blue Kachina prophecy, and then there's the man with the red hat.
There are two primary Hopi prophecies that are really apropos in our time.
And the man with the red hat prophecies is very informative to people wondering what the political situation in the United States of America might be over the next few years.
So I got done with that, and no sooner was I done, like, within a few hours, there were people over in these other UFOX spaces accusing me of appropriating Hopi culture.
So what is it, right?
Like, is it a community of people interested in UFOs, or is it just another puritanical ideological community?
I don't know.
It gets me kind of depressed to think about, to be honest, because there is no other place, right?
And we've come to the point where we're winnowed down to just a few people.
And if the people holding this puritanical ideology have out-screamed everyone else and canceled and run everyone else out, then there's no hope for any truth.
Because you can be an ideologue, and you can be a truth seeker, but you cannot be an ideologue truth seeker.
It just doesn't work.
It never has.
So, yeah, so the rock, right?
So it turns out that many Asian societies, Asian, Oriental, whatever, the Oriental areas that aren't part of Asia are under the ocean now, right, have these legends, have this folklore that strongly involves space.
So in European traditions, right, you had the archons of the planets, and people don't really know that.
That archons are both planets and beings who embody those planets, which, you know, in a less technologically advanced society, is an interesting way of talking about, like, aliens, right?
Like, you're talking about, like, an archon is a ruler of a planet, it's the planet, and it's his servants that live on this planet.
So it's like, okay, there are these, you know, there are aliens on these planets.
That's how we would look at it today.
And when Christianity took over, right, we moved away from our minds, and we switched to demonology.
Now, demonology goes back to pre-temple Judaism, and the demons were largely seen as being the spirits of the offspring of the watchers, the Nephilim, the Anunnaki.
So the Anunnaki, Nephilim watchers, fallen angels, landed in Mount Hermon in Israel, and they were here to find women.
Or that's one of the main motivators.
I didn't have women, which is an interesting thread that I'll follow in another space someday, I think maybe next week or the week after.
And they got wives, had kids, kids turned into giants, and then the giants were killed in the flood, but the kids were semi-divine.
They were different than all the human beings because they were the descendants of the Anunnaki, the watchers.
Their spirits survived and roamed the earth and became the demons.
I'm not saying that's what happened.
You know, I'm going to say that's what they believed.
It was the main explanation for demons in Judaism prior to the origin of Christianity.
So as Christianity emerged, right, we focused, people began to focus on the demons, and they forgot about the archons.
But the original Christians did talk about the archons.
As time went on, the archons were relegated to the aerial tollbooth theory, toll houses, aerial toll houses, which is still taught in some of Orthodox Christianity.
And then eventually the planets in their role was relegated to the seven deadly sins.
Each of those sins represents the modern or the memory of an archon and the planet that the archon represented in its role.
In human affairs.
So when the early UFO researchers came around, they had to sort of reconnect and invent connection between Roman society, Greek society, and space.
It would have been there in antiquity.
There was no question.
But it was de-emphasized.
And even when it was there in antiquity, it was not as explicit or dramatic as it was in Asia.
Civilization, right?
Like, okay, so Babylon, 4000 BC.
But, largely speaking, civilization began, well, I mean, Europe is just a peninsula of Asia.
So Europe is Asia.
But, largely speaking, civilization began in the Pontic Sea, which is east of the Black Sea.
So going through the Ukraine, Kazakhstan, you had, like, farming populations in what we consider the Mideast now and in Asia.
But these pastoralist tribes, horsemen, I think Mongols, or I think Sinan is from Turkey.
So the ancestors of the Turkic peoples, there were a lot of tribes that would roam around Asia.
Because if you get on a horseback in the far reaches of Russia, you can ride to Poland.
It's taking a long time, right?
But there are very few natural impediments along that way.
So there were tribes moving around in that whole area.
And they would come down and conquer the early agrarian civilizations, the early cities.
And so when you look at the record of, like, you know, how did civilizations start?
Well, it's, like, there were the agricultural communities.
But when they started to become cities was really when they started to be conquered by pastoralists.
And they developed, like, a class system where the warrior class, the ruling class, would be the descendants of these Central Asian tribes.
And the peasantry would be the descendants of the agriculturalists.
From that, right, there were people who would say, oh, Egyptian civilization is really 400,000 years old.
The Babylonian civilization is really 400,000 years old.
Indian civilization is really 400,000 years old.
Maybe.
Maybe outside of the simulation it is.
That's another thing to think about.
But when they look into the ruins in these areas, right, where they're going to, like, going all the way down into Cambodia and that area and the ruins they find in the jungle there, the Naga civilization.
And going all the way over, right?
From the best dating technology they have, it's relatively, it's around the same period of time.
There are a few outliers in Patagonia and Asia.
And, of course, I think we should all know, and I'm going to screw up the name, but there's Gobekli Tepe in Turkey.
And there are other sites around that area that are significantly older.
Going back to, like, 12,000 B.C., so about 14,000 years old, those sites don't have cities.
They have temporary structures and structures for people who are there, but they can't really find any evidence of long-term habitation.
And they think that people may have moved around and come there, or they were hunter-gatherers who work slowly or something, or another civilization, right?
Like, alternative thought would be another civilization, showed up and built it.
But as far as we know, the evidence for civilization is about 6,000 years, right?
And there was something before that, but it wasn't what we have now.
Like, it wasn't, you know, and it may have been more advanced.
We all know this, right?
If we're UFOX people, like, we all know that there are strong arguments that there were, or there are some arguments, I should say, that there were civilizations, cyclical civilizations, that end in catastrophes.
So the last one being around the time that Gobekli Tepe was Tepe, I'm never going to get the name correct, was constructed.
So it's possible there was a more advanced and evolved civilization that existed at that time.
And, and the remnants of that civilization have been destroyed in floods, and mudslides, and earthquakes, and just erosion.
Like, if they had metal and wood structures, they would erode with time.
And we wouldn't have any evidence of them left.
There are definitely, not to make this, you know, I'm going to switch back to just talking about Asia in a minute.
There is definitely a long history of people finding structures and devices that don't seem to belong underground in mines.
In coal seams is a famous one.
Coal miners used to find, or at least claimed to find, all kinds of things in the coal left over.
And the theory was that during periodic catastrophes, earthquakes, the ground would liquefy and the cities would, would sink 100 or 200 feet into the ground, which is something that can happen during an earthquake.
So if you had like a large universal earthquake, as part of the catastrophe, like the earth was just, everyone got a 10.10, you know, it's possible that that could be the case.
And the evidence for the advanced civilization is down there.
But in this, in the last 12,000 years, right, like we look back around 4,000 BC is when things seem to be happening.
That's the period that you had the, you had the waves of tribes from the pastoral area in Central Asia come in and take over.
And they did that in Asia as well.
So if you look at the historical information about India, by the way, there is some, not to make too much of a digression, but there is some interesting stuff.
So if you go into the caves of Europe, a lot of people don't know this.
I'm sure everyone here knows that there are cave paintings in Europe.
And Sinan knows that there are underground cities in Turkey, which there are.
There are large underground cities in Turkey.
That were probably built around the time of the cataclysm, but maybe afterwards, there's theories about it.
I don't know anything about any art found in those cities.
But I do know that in the caves in Europe, where they find the paintings, they also find sculptures.
And a lot of people don't realize that.
They don't know that there are sculptures of animals made out of clay.
I think it's just clay.
There might be some rock in those caves as well that date back, hypothetically, 40,000 years.
So if there was a civilization that was making sculptures like that, you know, it may have been pretty advanced.
And they could very well have been, there could have been sculptures all over the place in Europe at that time, above ground.
They would not be there anymore.
And the only place you could find them is in the ground.
Where you find these, they're pretty elaborate sculptures.
They're very impressive to see them.
That's not what you would imagine.
So civilization moves into, out of Central Asia, into the Mideast, into Iran, and into India.
And it is highly controversial.
The Chinese government, right, since the beginning of the CCP, has kept a strong lid on anything historical related to China.
It doesn't fit their particular narrative.
For whatever reason.
There could be a number of reasons.
This isn't a political conversation.
The reasons are most likely political.
But what a lot of people don't know is that China is loaded with pyramids.
Loaded with pyramids.
And there are photos, there's photographic evidence taken by American GIs or American pilots during World War II of massive white pyramids in China.
Much larger than the Great Pyramid of China, if you can believe that.
The Tibetan community, or in Tibetan history, strongly correlates with the Egyptian civilization.
As, by the way, did, there's a lot of evidence for an Egyptian-type civilization in the United States of America in history.
That's another strange thing that you have to study alternative history to find out.
There have been a number of discoveries, most famously in the Grand Canyon, of what seem to be Egyptian artifacts.
It's possible that the Egyptian civilization, back when we're talking about, right, 3,000, 4,000 BC was a global civilization.
So, Tibet and Egypt and maybe Mesopotamia were, you know, very similar at that time to what we are right now.
As far as nations interconnected with people moving back and forth, or communities, I'm not saying they had one world government, I don't know.
I think that would be kind of crazy with the geographic area.
But people were, it's called diffusionist history.
People were definitely moving back and forth a lot more than people have been told.
In Indian history, right, the Aryans came in from the north, and if you look at the language that they spoke, when you look at the Rig Veda, which is their earliest Indian Vedic text, it was composed in Pakistan, what's now Pakistan.
But the people who composed it weren't from Pakistan, they were probably from the Pontic State, right?
So they probably moved from the Black Sea down into Iran and over into India.
At that same time, there are some mummies found in China, in the Gobi Desert, and areas near the Gobi Desert in China, that are roughly categorized as Scythian.
So it was another tribe, group of tribes from that area, the Pontic State, that had red hair and blue eyes.
No one knows what people really look like, right?
So we all have a sense that people were darker on point in time, and then light skin came around.
Maybe that's true.
I don't doubt it.
There could be other explanations, though.
Yeah.
But we don't really know what, until people started drawing themselves, we don't know what the people in that given area looked like.
And people moved around a lot.
But we do know that there seemed that the same type of mummies that we find in the Ukraine and Kazakhstan, you find in China as well, in the western area of China.
And so the reason that's important is that you also find, right, that when we talk about, like, Pakistan, right?
Well, people are making judgments based on Pakistan today.
But that's not necessarily what was going on, right?
So the people who came down, and look, skin color shouldn't have anything to do with life today, right?
I'm not making a political or a racial statement.
I'm just, this is history.
So the Aryan people, of course, you know, looked Iranian, right?
Or historically Iranian, or even lighter.
And so that would be the people who came down into northern, down into northern India.
It's notable that they were also in China.
And it's notable for the reason that we have these stories from that period of time.
Hey, Ronald.
So these stories, these folk stories, and by the way, that's not just that area.
Because if you go over, right, to Japan, there are two predominant phenotypes in the Japanese population.
And one of them is the Jomen, who look a lot more western than East Asian.
They do definitely, like, they wouldn't look like someone in the streets of France.
But they definitely, like, not everyone in Japan has a strong East Asian look.
So it's always been the case that you've had groups of people who look different intermingling around the world.
And in Asian history, you do as well.
That's sort of contra to the CCP narrative of a 5,000-year civilization that's been roughly continuous.
So what was going on in the past?
Right?
Like, we know that there is information in the record.
So the Chinese and the Indians, the people of China and India, possibly Korea and Japan as well,
but particularly China and India, have a lot better records than other areas of the world.
And some of those records aren't taken as seriously because of the seeming legendary character of the events in the records.
But what you do find in those records is, one, outer space was part of life.
So in Vedic times, there were beings that traveled to and from planet Earth into space, according to the Vedic sources.
In ancient China, just as China was called the Middle Kingdom, because it was between the rest of the world and the Celestial Kingdom, which was the kingdom in space.
The Celestial Kingdom had an emperor.
They had a government.
And that government was connected.
And the emperor on Earth ruled in the name of the Celestial Kingdom.
Japan had or has legends and folktales of interaction with people from the moon.
Okay, so why is that important?
Well, if you look at the evidence, we'll start with the bottom.
Well, not the bottom.
God, that's centric too, right?
So we'll start with what we perceive as a lower country on the globe.
Equatorial.
We'll start with an equatorial country.
I'm trying so much to be, like, politically correct to the degree I can so I don't alienate people, but it's just not in my nature.
Okay, so culture is close to the equator.
India has, for some reason, in the models people have done of possible global floods slash pole shifts, et cetera, for whatever reason, I'm not, I can't tell you.
They have, like, 500,000 followers, so they're never going to come here and talk to me and explain it to everyone for me.
India is very stable.
What's up, Brian?
India is, weathers, pole shifts, and catastrophic events much better than other areas of the world.
In most models, when you look at the flooding, the flooding does not really penetrate India.
And it actually, the flooding is a bigger problem north of India in the Himalayas than it is in India itself.
Just, it's something about the centrifugal force or the location of the oceans, I don't know.
I just know that in the models that I've seen, India isn't as strongly affected, right?
So, if you're looking at a place where you would have a long-term or a strong cultural memory that would stretch back to antiquity, you'd look for the Indian continent.
Now, that memory, the folklore, those legends, right, have been retold in the Vedic texts.
The claim is these texts go back to, you know, how many thousands of years.
But in reality, it was an oral tradition before it was put in text.
So, the oral tradition goes way back, right?
Just like the Rig Veda was an oral tradition from Kazakhstan or the Ukraine that was eventually put in writing, you know, was eventually fully formulated in Pakistan and put in writing in northern India, right?
But this oral tradition, it could go back quite a long ways.
Probably not the type of numbers that are often used because they were inflated for political purposes, right?
So, you find this, like, with the study of the Great Year, right?
We all know what the Great Year is.
If you're an astrologer, you know what the Great Year is.
Most people, most modern people have an idea about a 20,000 year, 26,000 year procession of equinoxes, right?
So, the Indians multiplied that by 360.
And I don't mean that like all those Indians.
I'm saying, like, people in the past, Vedic scholars, particular Vedic scholars whose identities are known, whose names I don't know, but, you know, it's because I didn't bother to memorize them.
Inflated the figures by 360 years, or a factor of 360, times by 360, because it represented sacred time as opposed to actual time, right?
And it makes it a giant pain in the ass when you try to study things.
But it's also important to note if you're trying to reconcile the timescales.
So, what I can tell you is that NASA, right, has alloys that they used to put in the space shuttle that they bought from an Indian company.
That Indian company manufactured those alloys based on Vedic texts documenting the design and construction of Vamanas, the airship that they record in the Vedic legend.
So, in Vedic legend, the gods, the leaders, were flying around in these Vamanas, rich people, had, you know, airships that they flew around in.
They don't seem to be balloons.
Because they give a pretty good description of them.
I don't know if anyone has ever tried to make one.
I assume they have, but we just don't know about it.
They're odd.
They're odd when you see, like, what they would look like.
Almost like a, oh, God, like a dome, like a bunch of domes, like a, shit, like a, I'm trying to think, like a beehive with, like, a little top, and then the next level's a little larger, next level's a little larger, next level's a little larger.
And then the force was underneath it.
I know that was a terrible description.
I'm not very good at those things.
So, but they do, like, laboriously record the construction and the materials and the alloys involved.
And there were, there was, or there were companies in India.
I don't, I don't know anything about it now.
Because this was something, again, in the 90s, if you were part of the community, you would have exposure to this information.
But this is, like, lost in the vastness of the internet right now.
And these guys, UFOX guys, like, they don't have an exposure to anything.
I don't know jack shit, right?
No offense, but they, they, they, they do not.
So, um, I imagine this would be news to them.
Uh, they know about Vermanis, though.
Um, so anyhow, yeah.
Uh, they were selling alloys that they claimed that they had, um, deciphered from these texts.
So, with the texts themselves, right, there's a, a ton of Vedic texts.
You're going to hear about the Rig Veda, um, the Ramayana, right?
But there are giant libraries full of these texts that we're never going to hear about.
We're never going to see.
The language difference.
First of all, there aren't too many people, um, there aren't too many people reading them now in India, right?
And there aren't too many people in India who know the, the ancient dialect as it is, right?
Just like there aren't too many people in the West who know ancient Greek.
But, um, but it's, you know, it's relatively concealed, uh, to, you know, just by the type of interest it is.
But the real treasure trove is in Tibet.
There we get into the Chinese issue, right?
The real treasure trove is they stored a ton of these ancient documents in Tibet.
Uh, Tibet is another area that's relatively immune to catastrophic events.
And they find libraries, or they've found libraries in Tibet that have a hundred thousand, uh, untranslated ancient texts in them.
And a lot of them.
So, like, uh, Anthosophy, Theosophy, the modern American spiritual movement, um, New Age movement, began from the translation of a couple of ancient Tibetan texts.
Um, in the mid-1800s.
They have just piles of piles.
If you ever see a picture of the library, it's really impressive.
All of them, um, probably haven't been read for thousands of years since they were written down.
Uh, or at least a thousand years.
Again, it was an oral tradition for a while.
Um, but they, they do touch on technological issues as well.
Um, the Chinese have, um, of course, they've had a number of, uh, events in the past where their, their, uh, books have been destroyed.
Um, going back to, like, first emperor.
But they've had a number of emperors who have just rounded up and killed off all the intellectuals.
It's happened in the West, too.
And burned all the books.
So we don't know even what's missing, right?
Um, we don't even know if they know who built all the pyramids in China, right?
Um, that you're not allowed to photograph.
But, uh, they do have a lot.
And the language is, is, is, is the issue, right?
Um, if you have a few people in the West who are trained to speak, you know, to read and decipher ancient Chinese texts or, or ancient Vedic texts, you know, they have a teaching career, right?
That's how they make the money.
They don't, they spend a certain amount of time.
We don't really have a core of people that can, you know, spend the time occupied translating all this information.
We should, because there's a wealth of historical knowledge involved, but no one.
So they talked about space.
And, you know, the Chinese have a number of, uh, folklores and legends about space and people traveling to space.
So in the last, um, in the last 6,000 years, right?
We know that, um, well, six or 7,000 years ago, uh, we know that there's a record that in Indian culture, that they were more advanced.
That may have stretched to about a thousand BC, uh, in China, there have been like a number of waves, right?
So like, you guys may have heard that the Chinese had machine guns.
They did.
Um, the Romans had cars.
I don't know.
Spring-long cars though.
Um, but they had like technology and, and gizmos a number of times that they voluntarily gave up.
Like they gave up the machine gun.
Um, and other technological items, which I, I should have, you know, memorized, but it's been a long time.
This has happened like a couple of times in the last 6,000 years.
Um, but they're legends.
And again, like, this is tough because this is drawing off memory.
We're going back to that period of like 2000 BC to 4,000 BC when these things occurred.
Right.
But the Chinese have all kinds of folklore about, um, trips to space.
They have a moon expedition, a lunar expedition, at least two, two times the lunar expedition.
The Japanese folklore about people from the moon coming to Japan, right.
Is dated probably later than that.
And as we all know, um, at least in the case of the Japanese, um, you know, their, uh, imperial family was, you know,
traced back to the sun goddess, which you might interpret as being extraterrestrial in some way.
Uh, so what else do they have that, uh, we touch on in, in modern ufology today?
So we had, uh, this legend of a man, um, leading a, a lunar expedition sometime between two and 4,000 BC.
Again, I should have it memorized, but I don't.
Um, he settled on the moon.
He built, uh, a building on the moon called the palace of the moon.
And he, he brought 50 concubines with him.
Thus, the whole concept of moon people that pops up in, in, uh, from that point forward in Asian, um, legends.
So if you look into, um, I'm, I'm not positive about this, but I have never run into any information, uh, any legends and myths about any European civilization and antiquity colonizing the moon.
I, I, I, I, I haven't, I haven't run into anything about Mesoamericans colonizing the moon.
The caveat there is that Mesoamericans do have a myth that they're, or not a myth, a legend that they're from Mars, right?
The Mayans and the Hopis.
So we could draw like Mayans, Hopis, probably Aztecs into that fold.
So people in the Southwest from Mesoamerica up to the Southwest do, um, do believe that they're from Mars, as did the Egyptians, by the way.
That's another story.
Um, and the Tibetans, I think had a connection there as well.
But, you know, when you look at ancient legends, right, you don't really find anywhere else in the world that they are, they have these legends of colonizing the moon.
Well, so that's kind of apropos.
If you're someone who studies the, um, the legends now, right, the, the legends are myths, the constructs, the social constructs, now people talking about extraterrestrials.
The moon is a big part of that, right?
And, um, they talk about the moon being inhabited.
So then you get to, well, who do they talk about inhabiting the moon?
Well, I mean, let's, let's, let's look into it.
Like, do we know anyone who has legends of the point of the moon in the past?
Right?
Like, probably not the Greeks, definitely not the Norwegians.
Um, so then we look at what else is going on in Asia, right?
Disconnected.
So do we have any evidence in Asian legends of extraterrestrials on earth, right?
Because we do have it in, that we have in, in the Western antiquity, right?
Because they're the gods, they're the gods.
But how does that work out?
Well, you had the Anunnaki in Babylon, the watchers, the fallen angels, Nephilim.
You had the giants who were the descendants of the watchers, the Nephilim, et cetera.
They were not the only ones running around, right?
Um, they were interacting with other groups on the planet at that time.
And there is, uh, there is actually, okay, there is a Chinese legend or recorded as historical data, legendary historical data of interacting with people from the Middle East who were, uh, giants, not 300 feet tall.
I think they were 10 feet tall, if I recollect correctly, um, who traveled to China in a submarine.
Okay, I don't know, um, that's the legend.
And carried with them those pine cones.
You ever seen the, the pine cones in the purses?
If you look at, uh, if you look at, uh, Sumerian, um, carvings of Anunnaki and gods, they have, like, wristwatches, purses, and they carry pine cones in their hands.
Now, we assume that those are, like, who knows what, what it meant, right?
But they have them in those, like, they have those items on them.
So that's notable because those items are described by the Chinese.
And it's, they have a name where it's, like, the wing, wing pie or wing hoe.
I know it sounds like I'm making, but it's not.
Like, I'm not making a, I'm not making a funny there.
I'm not, I'm not saying something inappropriate.
Like, that's, it's wing something was the name that they had for the people who lived in Mesoamerica.
Not Mesoamerica.
Oh, fuck.
Sorry.
Uh, Mesopotamia.
The people who lived in Mesopotamia, who visited China, they had a name for the civilization.
They interacted with them.
That is apropos to the subject at hand of archons, right?
And, uh, Morgan will understand why.
Because the archon story really begins with a war.
And so when we look for the data about what happened historically that connects all these cultures together and sort of the beginning of this modern situation that we're in, we look for a specific, large, global war.
And believe it or not, there is evidence for that.
And that evidence is found in, uh, in Mesopotamia.
It's also found in the Harappan civilization of which is located in, right?
Which the ruins of which is located in Pakistan now, um, which was a civilization that was completely destroyed.
It was completely destroyed, uh, during the time of, um, Krishna, right?
And so it's recorded in the Vedas related to the wars that I believe Krishna fought.
I don't think it was the Ramayana.
It may have been, I may have the wrong guy, but I think it was Krishna.
I'm pretty positive about that.
I just don't want to, like, I just have a moment of hesitation.
So I want to make sure that I put that out there.
Like all this stuff is going on and say, well, were there any, like what we would consider to be extraterrestrials around them?
Right.
Because, you know, they're, they're found in art in the West, right?
They're, they seem to be mentioned.
In texts, depending on how you like read into the texts, the, the ancient Asian legends talked about a celestial kingdom in space, right?
Like that's the trying again, China is the middle kingdom because it's between the celestial kingdom in space ruled by a celestial emperor and the other kingdoms on earth.
Right.
So that was, it was like always part of Chinese legend.
And yes, the answer is yes.
To make a long story short, we have several groups of non-human humanoid beings recorded in the, the legends and histories of, of Asian people.
Everywhere in the Orient, right?
So, um, in specifically like the one that really pops, comes to mind, um, was known as the Nagas in, or is still known as the Nagas in India.
And the Nagas are a serpent-like, fish-like humanoid that lives underwater, possibly underground as well, but definitely underwater.
So they have cities at the bottom of the ocean.
So, the reason that might interest someone from UFOX is, right, that's where, right, isn't that the big, that's one of the big theories that was floating around before they got onto this whole angel, right, before they got onto this whole aliens or demons, right, which is a psyop in my opinion.
Um, the, they were talking a lot about, um, underwater, um, submersible objects, right?
Like, that, for as many UFOs as we see in the sky, we see a lot more, um, unidentified objects, uh, very large unidentified objects with, like, glowing lights and shit zipping around under the ocean.
Always have.
And, uh, so the theory is, and this was the theory, and this is notable because this is, precedes, immediately precedes the whole aliens or demons thing.
Um, they were giving, whistleblowers were giving, um, presentations to Congress where they were referring to these, uh, quote, extraterrestrials as actually being from the ocean, deep in the ocean.
Now, am I saying that's true?
No, I'm saying that's what people said, okay?
That's apropos because that's what the, you know, ancient culture said, right?
That's, we had that actually in, in ancient Greece and in Rome with Dogon, right?
Coming out of the ocean.
And, um, we also have that in, uh, India and China.
And in India, they were called the Nagas.
And, uh, what's interesting, this, Morgan will find this interesting, uh, they could shape change.
According to legend, they could shape change, right?
So, when modern researchers are talking about the potential for a civilization to bomb the ocean.
As far as we know, because it's hard to pin people down, but they're not really talking about, like, people, like, look like us.
Right?
So, not really humans, the story goes.
So, possibly one of the explanations for, like, the gray phenotype of humanoid, uh, is that they would be, you know, then they're ill-suited for living on land, but they would, you know, they would be better suited for living in water.
Because if you look at, especially in the deep, um, you know, they're not very bulky, like, fish in the deep aren't very bulky.
They're kind of, right?
And so, the whole, like, um, no ears and, and, like, real slim and almost frail looking would make sense, uh, if they were an underwater species.
Again, I'm not saying it's true.
I'm just saying nothing people say.
Um, they also, um, have sort of serpentine fish-like, uh, stuff going on, features, whatever.
Um, in China, they were called dragons.
So, like, what we call dragons aren't, like, what they're talking about, right?
Like, we have big, heroic smog, you know, from Lord of the Rings.
But they were talking about, like, shape-changing serpents that lived underwater.
And, um, I don't remember what they called them in Japan, but this was sort of, this was, like, sort of something that they were talking about living with them.
Right?
Um, so you can't, like, look back on English history and say, well, let's find evidence for, you know, if you have, like, the, I'm not saying, you know, I don't even know if I believe in gray aliens.
But if gray aliens are real, right, and they show up in a bedroom in someone's cottage in England, like, there's no precedent for that.
People could, could make all kinds of stories up about it.
But when you, when you look at, um, you know, if that happened in India, China, right, if it happened in China, it would, it would be a, a dragon.
If it happened in India, there would be a naga, right?
If it happened in, um, if it happened in, uh, South America, they, they call them ant people.
Or, you know, in the native populations of the Southwest, right?
For instance, the Hopis believed that they were, uh, sheltered during the last cataclysm underground by the ant people, lived on it.
That's the, the, the, the, these, these beings or something similar to these beings does show up in remote viewing data.
Um, so we've got this rock in Tibet that they claim was brought back from the moon 6,000 years ago.
We have stories in China of people going to the moon and building a, a, a building on it called the moon palace 4,000 years ago.
And going up there with a bunch of concubines and reproducing.
We've got stories in Japan of people coming down from the moon and living with them and then going back up to the moon again.
Uh, and those descriptions, uh, are very white.
And I don't mean that in a racial sense.
I mean, skin, very pale white.
Now, like that would make sense, right?
Like if a person was living on the moon, say there would be inside, uh, all the time, they wouldn't be getting any sun.
So they'd be, they would have tendency to be very pale.
Um, I do think they were described as having brown hair.
And so the reason this is interesting and apropos is that when remote viewers look at the moon, I've seen different, you were, yeah, different remote viewers say different things are up there.
Right.
But the consensus seems to be that whatever is up there, um, there are blonde people up there.
All right.
So they call it Nordics.
So when you get into the discussion of where, so this is apropos because these Nordics are often argued by some to be the Anunnaki.
I'm not saying they are, um, they're argued by some to be the archons.
Right.
Um, we don't, in, in the, in the roofing data, the descriptions given of the, of these beings don't tend to, or at least that I've seen, don't tend to cover their, that aspect of their appearance.
I've, I've heard them described as being very veiny, like veins, right?
Which, um, which even when they were seeing them on Mars, which that, that has also happened, right?
They're described as having like very prominent veins.
So their skin would be so pale that the veins are showing up all over their bodies, like that level of paleness.
Right.
When I say white, I mean, I don't mean Caucasian.
I mean like chalk white, but blue veins all over the place.
Um, they are described by contactees as, as looking like Swedes, right?
But that's not what's really going on.
Um, that seems to be some sort of transition.
So people who've looked into it to believe this type of thing.
Um, I'm not making an argument for true or false.
I'm saying this is what people are saying.
We'll believe this type of thing.
Right.
Like, uh, there are some really tall ones that are really chalky and pale and they've got veins all over the place.
And then there are some smaller ones who might be like along the lines of like hybrids.
Right.
And those are the ones that look like Swedes.
So the ones that people think in the, in the sixties, fifties, sixties, and seventies, when people saw them getting out of spaceships, they weren't seeing the leaders getting out of spaceships.
They were seeing the peons get out.
Right.
And the peons look like Swedes, you know, but about seven feet tall, whereas the, uh, the aristocracy or the leaders, whatever would be nine feet tall and, uh, super, super pale and, um, weirdly thin.
You know where, uh, you can see this, uh, this was the basis for the miners in the expanse.
So if you see the first season of the expanse, or if you read the books, the miners like nine feet tall, cause the absence of gravity, um, that, that was based on the, I think was based on the reports of these, of these extraterrestrial populations.
Okay.
So this is what people are seeing up there.
Um, UFO content, tactics, uh, and when you look at, um, in myth, you find those people represented a little bit.
In European myth, you find them heavily overrepresented in Asian legends and history.
So we fixate, the modern people are fixate, fixated on people's appearance, right?
Like, and, um, divisions of, of race or what we perceive as being racial divisions.
There are a lot of theories why we have different, um, you know, um, races, whatever it is.
I mean, I think race is a sort of an aging term, but that's, you know, that's the one we all grew up with.
So like the reasons why we have people who, who look differently and living in different parts of the globe.
And that's not the subject of this discussion today.
Um, but as I was pointing out, like, we don't know what people look like, like 5,000 years ago, 6,000 years ago.
That's something that pops up in the Hopi prophecy.
I mentioned earlier where they said, like, you know, um, when you're trying to identify the descendants of the groups that people talk about ancient history, including the Hopi myth, they said, don't.
You know, judge that based on what people look like today, because people did not look the same, like people move around the planet.
Like they, people's appearance changes, people's like, not an individual, but a people's appearance changes as they move around.
Um, there have been, um, there have been people who have claimed to get, and this is weird, um, there have been people who have claimed to get like genetic samples off of these, these, uh, extraterrestrials.
Whatever, the, the ones that look like people.
And when that genetic material was analyzed, um, there were, uh, genes associated with, um, Russians and, um, Mongolians and people from East Asia.
So, which is exactly what we're talking about, right?
Like Asia is a vast steep where people moved around a lot.
That's where civilization sort of sprung up from.
And so I, you can't, if you have a remote view or any views people on Mars or on Mars, yeah, on, uh, on the moon and says they're Nordic, that's an impression.
Unless, you know, you were to have like, um, you were to invest enough money and time to get them to look into the ancestry of the people on the moon, right?
In which case maybe they would be able to come up with, you know, perceptions that supported the idea they were from Norway.
But generally speaking, when we say Nordic aliens, we're talking about an appearance.
So you can't say they're not, they're not from Asia and that trips people up, right?
They hear Nordic and all, all they can think about is, is crazy white supremacists.
And, uh, and they start fixating on a Eurocentric view of the phenomenon.
We may have a Eurocentric view of modern life, but you can't have a Eurocentric view of what happened in antiquity because it's just not real.
So the, um, the gods that people brought with them out of the Pontic steep, um, both into India and into Iran and then diffused outward, right?
So there were two groups, you had Devas and Asuras and, um, the, the group that went into, um, into India, the Aryans who descended into India.
I'm using Aryan in the historical term sense.
This is not, again, there's nothing to do with white supremacy.
They, um, the Devas were the good guys, uh, to them.
And the Asuras were sort of monstrous, but, uh, over in Iran, the exact opposite was the case.
And, um, they had problems with, uh, Deva worshipers coming out of, um, coming out of, uh, in tribes coming out all blitzed out on drugs.
Cause there were very heavy drug users coming in and murdering everyone.
And again, these people weren't from India.
They were from the Pontic steep.
Um, so like in Zoroastrianism, it starts with, you know, like modern organized monotheistic religion begins as their reaction to the raids from these people.
He's blitzed out, like drugged out horse warriors riding in and killing everyone.
And Zoroastrian founded the modern religions based on a reaction to them.
Um, so the English word devil, right?
That, that is the etymology of devil goes back to Deva, which is what the Hindus call the gods.
Uh, so the Western gods, um, would be divided, uh, into Titans, right?
And Olympians.
And those gods were brought from Asia, either through Syria or most likely from the Pontic steep, most of them, by the original, uh, horsemen who came in and sort of conquered and, and created the culture and civilization.
So they were the same, the archons were there, right?
So the archons were involved and they were discussed in, in the Rig Veda.
They were discussed in Perdo-Indo-European as being two groups and, um, who you thought were the good guys versus the bad guys depended on your position.
And that continued into antiquity where they were looked at as Prometheans and Titans.
And, um, in Iran, where Zoroastrian became a reaction to the, the Devas.
So these are the people that we refer to as the archons, at least from the perspective of antiquity.
So, um, I think, you know, Morgan, um, I know you're a listener.
You can correct me because I wanted to touch base with Morgan about some of these facts.
Because I don't want to, um, miscommunicate something that I learned from him or talking to him.
And that's, it's, it's difficult because as time goes on, memory is imperfect.
I don't have the documents, right?
To touch back on.
So I get a, I get a constantly contact Morgan and ask him the same questions year after year.
Hey, you know, was this in there or am I kind of imagining it?
Um, and it's definitely true that, um, the East Asian imagery isn't, um, isn't very strong in what they see.
If it's there at all, it may not be there at all.
Right.
Um, as far as the origin of the reality overlay and the art fonts, um, it does, there are some analytical overlays that have, uh, an East Asian feel to them.
Um, I don't know if, if much comes up from, uh, like a Vedic cultural, um, feel or, uh, aesthetic.
But they do describe three right parties and Morgan, you can correct me if I'm wrong.
You can come up and speak if I'm, if I'm not being accurate.
And so the, the beginning of the reality overlay, um, was the result of a global war.
And that war, um, wiped everyone out.
And of those three groups, we don't have descriptions for two of them.
I would kind of do though, because the, the individuals present during the creation of the reality overlay, or at least the period where humans began to be altered, um, were very stocky.
They're big.
And, uh, they may be, right.
I've had conversations with Morgan where I, I was able to say like, is it possible they were at the Anunnaki and it's possible, but they don't want to jump to assumptions.
Right.
They don't want it.
They just want to relate just their job is to relate what they perceive.
That's not my job.
That's their job.
Right.
So someone like me comes in and says, Oh, well, let's look at all the history and see, can we make connections?
That's not what they want to do.
Right.
They wouldn't be good remote viewers if they did that.
Um, but there's a third party involved.
So the side that wins the war, um, and at least in some of the, at least in one of the sessions, there was a third party.
I think there were an ambassador that could be a projection that I'm putting on the data who fit the description of like a gray shape-changing alien.
Please say, Oh, well, okay.
It's got to be extraterrestrial.
It's going to be like a civilizational galactical war.
Right.
Cause we know that these beings are in space.
We know that they were immortal.
Right.
Some of them like the bad guys, the biological immortals, the archons.
So they're in space.
They're immortal.
Um, so they must be from, you know, are they from Aldebaran or from the Pleiades?
Where are they from?
All of those groups are present here in, in, according to legends and lore of, um, of Asian, you know, of, of, uh, East Asia and, uh, Southeast Asia.
Uh, when we talk about like immortals, right?
Well, where do we find that?
So we find that in Southeast Asian, um, or East Asian, uh, lore and, and legends.
So it's not so much as like a thing in the West.
We have like Longinus, he's immortal because he put a spear in the side of Jesus when Jesus was on the cross.
Right.
Um, we have people of the middle ages who, um, sought immortality, like Count St. Germain.
But even the way that they learn, the way like Count St. Germain became immortal was by contacting a brotherhood in the East of immortals who lived in the East.
So if you trace Western esotericism back, the immortals behind it, they live in Asia.
Right.
We're in Asia.
We don't know.
Central Asia, probably, uh, Gobi Desert, maybe, um, hidden cities, right?
Shambhala, Agartha.
Uh, there are all kinds of different descriptions of how that might work.
Those pop up in other groups, remote viewing, not in Morgan's groups, remote viewing, where they find a lot of information about how, uh, about subterranean realms and, um, how this concept of like different dimensions might work and how the gateways could be underground generated by this PZO electric current that occurs when tons of rock push in crystal pushing against each other.
Um, there's, there's, there's information about that in, in the remote viewing community.
Um, there is information about in, in Chinese folklore and legend and in other remote viewing groups, not Morgan's group, about people making contact with, um, biological immortals, uh, in caves underground.
Um, but they don't really live underground.
They live in a different dimension, but the caves underground where it's super dense and heavy, um, are the gateway.
Um, and, um, there is a whole religion slash tradition that sprung up around the idea of the immortals, Taoism, which is based on internal cultivation, right?
Where you are able to, um, and it's spread by the way, because it's also in Tibetan Buddhism with the rainbow body, um, where you are able to generate an immortal body.
Um, by, uh, meditation practices involving transmuting energies in your body, the way they flow.
And, um, so the Taoists sought immortality.
According to legend, some of them became immortals.
When I originally heard the Moksha video put out by Brett Stewart, a former associate of Morgan's, uh, his description of the biological immortals strongly reminded me of the remote viewing descriptions of these Chinese, um, immortals.
That having been said, we don't know the provenance because the information isn't necessarily the same.
And so it's possible that the information that he related wasn't accurate in the session data.
And when I talked to Morgan, it seems that there really isn't much information about what they look like, um, or descriptor information.
So that may have been something that Brett found elsewhere, right?
However, um, if we are looking for ancient technological civilizations, um, we look at the Babylonians and, you know, and people in Mesoamerica, right?
There are stels, there are, um, car wall carvings of people riding on what looked like rockets into space, what looked like space shuttles, right?
Into space and, and rockets.
Um, that's certainly, and they have, um, like in Egypt, there are carvings that resemble airplanes, helicopters, submarines.
Okay.
So there is evidence of technology, but not to the extent of the Vamanas, not to the extent of traveling to the moon, et cetera.
That technology, that evidence is found in the legends of, of, um, of Northern India and, and China, right?
Um, Tibet, Tibetan, China, Northern India, Tibetan, China.
Um, so if we were looking for a culture or series of cultures thousand years ago, however many thousand years ago, it could be longer, it could be 400,000 years ago.
It wouldn't matter because if we live in a reality overlay, if we live in a simulation, our time is not the same as time at the base reality, right?
So, uh, if we look at that information and we look for a connection, um, we would certainly be looking more likely in Asia than anywhere else for the, or in a now submerged, right?
So Atlantis, um, Lemuria, and, uh, and then the cultures that branch off from them, which are in Asia.
And we were looking for, there for the evidence of the type of technology that it would take to create a reality overlay.
And that's the same type of technology it would take to get to the moon.
I mean, it's not the exact same, right?
But like, where did we get the computer technology?
Like where, where, you know, uh, our space program is what generated the technology that we have right now.
Um, what, that we use to create these digital simulations.
Now, here's the PSD resistance.
There is a, um, there is a thing going on now where people are taking DMT and shining lasers on walls.
And the reason they do this, and several thousand people have done it, and they're all reporting that when they take DMT and they shine these lasers on the walls in a certain way, they see a stream of characters like the numbers in the Matrix, right?
So in the Matrix movie, reality was made up of numbers that only Neo could see, you know, only the living programs could see.
Other people couldn't see the numbers that make it up, right?
So these people taking the DMT are shining the lasers on the wall and they're seeing characters, but they're not seeing numbers.
The characters are described as most closely resembling Japanese kanji.
Asian characters, right?
And I mean, East Asian characters, uh, the, that come from China that are used in China, uh, the Koreas and Japan, uh, and possibly Thailand as well.
I don't really know if the, if the Thais and the Vietnamese use, uh, Chinese characters.
So that is what people are seeing when they are seeing the inside of the, um, of the Matrix.
They are not seeing Western letters.
They're not seeing, uh, Greek letters, not seeing anything from the Phoenician alphabet.
They're not seeing numbers.
They're seeing what appears to be something like, um, Chinese or Japanese characters.
So, I mean, connected, who knows?
Is it interesting in light of the fact that if we were going to look at evidence in the historical record for cultures that were technologically advanced back in the, in that time?
Yeah, it is interesting.
And so what about the war?
Well, the war was there, right?
So the war was fought between, it's, it's in the records of the Mesopotamians.
That's where the Anunnaki went.
You say, well, why don't we have Anunnaki, Nephilim, Watcher, Fallen Angels here now?
Or if they're here, why are they in hiding?
Well, it's because there was a war.
It was a massive war between the, or including possibly Mesoamerica, but it was mainly fought between the Anunnaki that were in charge of Mesopotamia and the Anunnaki that were in charge of Northern India.
It involved weapons that created large clouds that killed everyone, including the people in cities, like whole cities.
In Mesopotamia, the Mesopotamian records say that most Anunnaki left.
They fled to the sky, but some stayed to die with the people because they loved the people.
And they were wiped out when the gas clouds wiped out their cities.
If you look at the Northern India slash Pakistan area involved, you find the Harappan civilization, Mojodaro, I think is how you pronounce the city, right?
There are like nine plus cities that were destroyed.
And those are one of the, those are some of the places where they talk about ancient evidence for nuclear war.
The evidence being that the rock is fused through the application of extreme heat and the ground is fused into glass, which is something we've only been able to create by exploding nuclear weapons.
In the descriptions in the Vita, they are throwing missiles, they are throwing javelin-like weapons around.
And those javelin weapons are creating rays and the rays are killing people.
They also have weapons that just create rays, but they're also creating explosions and they're creating clouds.
And the clouds kill off everyone.
And so when you look at that, when you look at those sources, that, that war was either 4,000 BC or 2,000 BC.
And as I was pointing out, we don't really know any, you know, we don't know for certain what the, the, the different, um, dating, you know, is like if how accurate our dating is, their accurate, their dating is.
We took a bunch of different calendars, all of which had been altered for political and religious reasons and histories that have been altered for political reasons, religious reasons.
And we smooshed them together and we used the process of elimination to come up with a rough idea.
Um, but I don't, you know, I'm not an expert.
There might be experts that would come in here and tell you like, oh, it's definitely possible to say exactly what year this happened to this city in Mesopotamia.
I don't believe it.
I think that we're, you know, it, it could be off by a couple thousand years.
Um, I think it's very likely the same event.
It could be two events.
However, as I have often pointed out, and to wrap it up, uh, floods, dreams, visions, prophecies, imagery, flood imagery, um, is related in the collective unconscious to wars.
So when people have dreams or visions of floods, um, they are often having, uh, visions of warfare.
Now, we know this from looking at Carl Jung and J.R.R. Tolkien, who both had visions, not dreams, visions of floods wiping out Europe prior to World War II, that they were both understood were fulfilled by that war occurring.
Um, it's the connection to the blood, rivers of blood, right?
Oceans of blood, like that's, floods of blood.
Um, it's a metaphor.
It's, it's deeply tied into the collective unconscious mind.
Uh, it has always been that way, right?
It's part of, it's part of who we are.
It's, like I said, it's hardwired into us, which by the way, to quickly digress, like when you look at the global warming map of the United States of America,
America, this is like a minor digression, but when you look at the global warming map of the United States of America, in the areas they predict will be flooded as a result of global warming.
Those areas are the blue coastal areas that one political party predominates.
So if you look at a map of the, the, the elections, our presidential elections, and a map of the global, the projections of global warming flooding in the United States, right?
They're the same.
They're virtually the same.
The red areas being the unflooded areas, the blue areas on the coast being the flooded areas.
And I've often wondered, um, and I've brought this up to, to young Ian experts, if those, those maps, those projections were, um, emerging from the collective unconscious as, as an indicator of, of future, future conflict.
Right.
And I think we see that happening now.
So I'm not saying the flooding isn't actual flooding because we do also predict flooding, right?
Hole shifts type flooding and, and flooding on the coast as a result of a weapon in the Atlantic at some point, like that's things that remote viewers see.
Um, but there could also be, uh, emergent archetype metaphor emerging from the collective unconscious warning that those areas are going to be subject to, to, to warfare.
So the great flood, um, pole shifts happen, flooding happens.
We know that because there are like seashells on the top of mountains, right?
And, you know, you go to mountains and you dig in there and you find seashells.
Um, but is it just flooding that occurred?
Like we know there was a flood 12,000 years ago.
We know there was a localized flood 6,000 years ago.
Is it possible there was a global flood 6,000 years ago?
Yes, absolutely.
Is it possible that the memory of the flood is partially about a flood and partially about a war that wiped everyone out?
I think it is.
So we're looking at a time period and saying how, how and when might this occur, right?
Like, you know, we've got a civilization that had a palace on the moon, right?
And when we look at, uh, when we, when we're looking at like who runs the soul system, not Morgan's group, other groups, look at that, right?
Like what the, what's with the dominant group in the soul system, they live inside the moon supposedly, right?
Where this palace of the moon was, which is the building, by the way, they claim that take pictures of on the moon, right?
So they claim to take pictures of the actual building itself.
Um, I think it is highly likely that the archons, um, just like the gods that, you know, we remember them as came from Asia.
And I think that for the Orient and by the Orient, I mean like somewhere to the East, Lemuria or, you know, um, off of the coast of Indonesia before that land went under the ocean.
And, uh, it's quite possible that they were fighting against the, the Mesopotamians, the giants who by giant, I'm not talking about, you know, 30 feet tall, tall.
I'm talking about nine feet tall.
We still have nine feet tall, nine foot tall people born today, right?
Um, we certainly know that in, in historical records, they were having, uh, they were interacting with each other.
And it would also, when we look at the events where like modern humanity came from during that period of time, right?
Like, um, the descriptions were that I recollect and Mormon can correct me, you know, um, the descriptions of the people involved were sort of a darker, like us or the people involved in the beginning of the process, like the prisoners.
We're sort of like darker skin, flat faces type, type people.
Um, and then the, the people conducting the experiment were stocky or bigger, but they may not, uh, the conversations I've had with Dan Mann, Morgan's, uh, associate in the past, they may not have been the ones in charge.
Um, they may have been the ones, um, his perspective when we talked seemed to be that they were being compelled by the victor, by the winning party to do the experiments.
All three of these groups present are recorded in, in, in historical data in Asia.
So were they in space?
Yeah.
I mean, there's no question that they're recorded in space, right?
The, the Anunnaki were recorded in space, Nephilim recorded in space, the, the ancient East Asians and the Vedic peoples were flying around in Vamana in space.
So, like, if the remote viewing calls them space dicks, okay, could they be space?
Yeah, absolutely.
Could they be, like, spreading through the universe?
Yeah, it's possible.
It's possible they're spreading through the solar system.
It's possible they're spreading on multiple dimensions.
It's possible they're spreading through the galaxy, right?
Um, but they still could have been here.
I'm thinking.
So, if, if, you know, remote viewing data came out that said this wasn't the case, like, I've heard other remote viewers refer to, um, come up with the word terror to describe Earth prior to the reality overlay.
T-E-R-R-A, which is the ancient name for Earth, right?
People who don't really know much about the ancient world.
Um, if, like, Morgan came to me and he said, hey, we've got this remote viewing data, and no, they clearly came from Aldebaran.
Um, then I'd be like, okay, you, you're, you're the expert on that.
I'm not the expert.
But I think that as of right now, we should be looking for evidence here, residual evidence from outside the, you know, um, reality overlay.
Because the whole point of having a reality overlay, of having a simulation, is great emergent solutions to, um, to problems that would also present themselves on base level reality.
Uh, so you'd start off from a point of common reference, right?
Like, you wouldn't create, um, a blue cotton candy world.
Like, if we're running a simulation, those of us here in this space are running a simulation, hypothetically, to solve, you know, to come up with solutions to possible problems we might face, we wouldn't set that simulation in a blue cotton candy world.
We'd set it in a world, um, based on a similar starting point, right?
Like, we'd say like, okay, we're going to start this simulation here in 2026 in, in New England or someplace else in the United States or Canada or Turkey or et cetera, or England, you know, and England, and we're going to move forward from there.
I mean, like, things might get, like, really weird.
Like, in a couple of iterations, you know, in, in game time or simulation time in a couple thousand years, things might be so weird, they have no resemblance whatsoever to reality at base level.
But they would probably start with a resemblance to reality at base level.
So we're probably looking for that evidence in the historical record.
It is my argument.
And I think it's, I think it's a good argument, but I'm open to, um, I'm open to, to looking at it.
Now, usually I would want to, like, hang out with everyone and, and talk and ask, you know, see if anyone had any questions.
It's Thursday and I try to wrap up around eight because I have a, another thing that I do at eight o'clock on Thursdays.
At least right now, that might change.
I really appreciate everyone coming.
Um, Melissa, I really appreciate you.
Barkley, Goduck, Sally, I really appreciate you.
Ronald, Sinon, Fletcher, and Morgan, I appreciate you.
I'm sorry you couldn't co-host today, but, uh, I'm sure you'll correct me if I screwed up and I will, um.
I will mention that first thing in the next space.
I'm going to try to, uh, don't freak out if I don't make the space tomorrow, but I'm going to try to run a space tomorrow on, on the stuff that's going on UFOX because I think that it has personal ramifications for all of us, um, who are loosely associated with UFOX, right?
I've never been a member, but I got involved in spaces.
So that, um, that makes me loosely associated, I guess.
Uh, and then I'm going to try to, I plan on running a remote viewing space on Saturday, but I haven't come up with the exact title yet.
And we'll be back again on next Thursday, or I'll be back again on next Thursday with a arc.
And I think that I'm going to talk specifically about the fallen angels, uh, whom I refer to as 200 griefers, um, as the next Thursday's topic.
Like there's actually a guy on Instagram.
He's, it's great.
If you like interesting, weird accounts, it's great where he, he has a theory that, um, actors and political, you know, this whole, like Nicholas Cage never dies.
There are pictures from the civil war, that whole theory.
He's got this whole theory that the fallen angels are here and they're, they're acting as like politicians and actors.
And they've been alive this whole time, including like famous individuals.
And he's got like, like who they were in their last, like, uh, anyhow, I think it's interesting because it, I don't necessarily agree with it, but it goes along with the 200 griefer theory, which is a theory of how some people outside of the reality overlay might.
Use the reality overlay as a sort of virtual reality simulation that they can enter and leave where the rest of us can't, but I'll save that for next time.
Thank you all for coming.
Pleasure.
Good to see you.
Um, Melissa, Morgan, Barkley, Doc, Sennon, Sally, I will, uh, I will hopefully see you, um, soon tomorrow, the next day, next week.
Um, thank you for listening.
Bye.
Thank you.